الكثير من الناس ينتقدون بشدة
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي بما في ذلك بعض الإسرائيليين
ويقبل الكثيرون في تقاريرك
وصف الاعتقالات
الإدارية للاضطهاد ضد الفلسطينيين
وإنكار حقوق أساسية معينة
للفلسطينيين سيستخدمون كلمات
مثل القهر والاستبداد
والتمييز على سبيل المثال ولكنهم
يقولون ذلك  من حيث يتوقف ، أخبرنا
لماذا تسمي هذا الفصل العنصري
الذي نسميه الفصل العنصري لأنه يمثل
فصلًا عنصريًا بموجب القانون الدولي ،
لقد أمضينا أربع سنوات في التحقيق
على الأرض لإجراء تحليل قانوني
مع بعض من أفضل العقول القانونية بشأن
جريمة الفصل العنصري.  لقد وجدت هو
نظام نظام من القوانين
والسياسات البيروقراطية المعقدة
الموجودة
هناك من أجل ضمان السيطرة
والسيطرة على الشعب الفلسطيني
ومن أجل ضمان
الهيمنة الديموغرافية لمجموعة عرقية
واحدة على أخرى ومن أجل ضمان
السيطرة القصوى على  الأرض التي
هي تعريف نظام
أ  partheid الذي تعرفه أن هذه هي
زيارتي الأولى لأم إلى إسرائيل ،
وقد صدمت حتى النخاع
بإيجاد مدى الفصل داخل
تلك المجتمعات إلى أي مدى
يتم فصل الناس بين الناس غير متساويين
في المدى الذي يصل إليه الفصل العنصري و
لقد تم استيعاب النظام
لدرجة أنه أصبح مبتذلاً تقريبًا
وعبثيًا في بعض الأحيان ، صحيح أن
نظام الفصل العنصري الإسرائيلي قد دحض
هذا التقرير كما هو الحال مع الآخرين في الماضي من
خلال وصفه بأنه
معاد للسامية ما هو ردك على
تلك
النظرة
أه تعرف  ملاحقة الرسول هي
إحدى الطرق لضمان عدم وجود
نقاش حول الجوهر الذي نحتاجه
للتركيز على واقع الحياة بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين ، تقف منظمة العفو الدولية إلى جانب
تقريرها وتقف إلى جانب حقها في انتقاد
إسرائيل في كل مرة تنتهك فيها إسرائيل
القانون الدولي
معاد للسامية يقوم بعملنا
كمنظمة دولية لحقوق
الإنسان بنفس الطريقة التي
ننتقد بها مجموعة من البلدان بغض النظر
عن
البكالوريا الدينية الخاصة بهم  kground على تركيبهم
العرقي وما إلى ذلك وهلم جرا وهذا
ما نحن هنا لأننا نريد أن نتعامل
مع جوهر ما وجدناه
وهو عدد كبير من انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان التي ترقى إلى جريمة
الفصل العنصري ، أريدك أن تسمع المزيد
من أه
الرد الإسرائيلي فقط استمع إلى
ما قاله وزير الخارجية
بدلاً من البحث عن الحقيقة
العفو يردد نفس الأكاذيب التي تشاركها
المنظمات الإرهابية
خمس دقائق من الفحص الجاد
تكفي لمعرفة أن
ما يسمى بالحقائق في التقرير  الذي نشرته
منظمة العفو هذا الأسبوع
وهمي ومنفصلون عن الواقع.
إسرائيل ليست مثالية
لكننا ديمقراطية ملتزمة
بالقانون الدولي منفتحة على النقد
بصحافة حرة ونظام قضائي قوي ومستقل
لا يسمي العفو سوريا حيث
قتل النظام  نصف مليون
من مواطنيها في دولة الفصل العنصري
ولا إيران
أو الأنظمة القاتلة الأخرى في جميع أنحاء
العالم فقط
إسرائيل
أنا
أكره استخدام الحجة القائلة بأن  إذا
لم تكن إسرائيل دولة يهودية ، فلن يجرؤ أي شخص في منظمة العفو الدولية على
تقديم مثل هذا الادعاء ضدها
ولكن في هذه الحالة
ببساطة
لا يوجد تفسير آخر
لردك ، فهذا أمر مثير للسخرية
في المقام الأول إذا كان هذا
الرجل قادرًا على مراجعة 300 صفحة
وثيقة مكتوبة بشكل كثيف للغاية في خمس
دقائق حقًا لا أعرف حقًا أنه يجب أن يكون
خارقًا ، لذلك هذا هو أول شيء
يرجى قراءة التقرير الذي سيستغرق وقتًا
ولكن الأمر يستحق ذلك ثانيًا ، العفو
منظمة غير متحيزة
بالطبع لقد استنكرنا  انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان ضد الإنسانية
التي ارتكبتها القوات السورية بالطبع شجبنا ومازلنا
نستنكر ما تفعله إيران
بشعبها منذ عام 1988 فصاعدًا ، وكتبنا بشكل
مكثف حول ما حدث في عام 1988 في
إيران والمذبحة التي حدثت كما
فعلنا.  مكتوبة على نطاق واسع حول الجرائم
ضد الإنسانية التي ارتكبتها الصين
، نعم ونعم ، نركز أيضًا على إسرائيل لأن
إسرائيل من خلال سياساتها
وممارساتها يتم تنفيذها  نظام
الجانب العلوي ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا ما
يخبرنا القانون الدولي لاستنتاجه وهذا ما
نفعله